FOR BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>>> REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS IN
TEXAS NOW LAUNCHING A SECOND
EFFORT TO PASS SWEEPING VOTING
RESTRICTIONS AT A SPECIAL
SESSION CALLED BY THE GOVERNOR.
TEXAS DEMOCRATS BLOCKED
REPUBLICANS' FIRST ATTEMPT IN
MAY BY STAGING THAT DRAMATIC
WALKOUT.
THE REPUBLICANS THERE DID
CONCEDE TWO OF THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL PROVISIONS, LIMITS
TO EARLY SUNDAY VOTING HOURS AND
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER FOR COURTS TO OVERTURN
ELECTION RESULTS.
MEASURES THAT MAKE CASTING
MAIL-IN BALLOTS HARDER, BANNING
DRIVE-THRU VOTING CENTERS AND
PARTISAN POLL WATCHERS ALL STILL
IN THE PROPOSAL THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS SPECIAL SESSION.
>>> JOINING US NOW, ATTORNEY AND
CONTRIBUTING COLUMNIST AT THE
WASHINGTON POST, GEORGE CONWAY.
>> HI.
>> NICE TO SEE YOU HERE.
>> THANKS.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON IN TEXAS?
INEVITABLE GOVERNOR ABBOTT WOULD
CALL THIS SPECIAL SESSION TO
PUSH THIS THROUGH.
THE COURTS IN GEORGIA AND OTHER
PLACES HAVE SAID, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TOUCH THIS RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, WILL WE SEE THIS MARCH
THROUGH THE COUNTRY?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
SEEING.
WE ARE SEEING THAT LOTS OF
STATES ARE DOING THIS.
IT'S UNCLEAR TO ME, AT LEAST, TO
WHAT EXTENT THIS WILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON VOTING.
SOME OF THEM -- SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS ARE BAD.
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS ARE
SO-SO.
THE THINGS THAT CONCERN ME,
THOUGH, ARE THE PROVISIONS THAT
TRY TO RESTRICT OR PUT
LIMITATIONS OR CHANGE HOW VOTES
ARE COUNTED AND HOW VOTES ARE
TABULATED, AND THE RULES ABOUT
CHALLENGING THE RESULTS.
BECAUSE THAT'S -- THAT TO ME IS
WHERE THE RUBBER MEETS THE ROAD.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY,
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO VOTE ARE
GOING TO VOTE.
BUT THE PROVISIONS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO OVERTURN POTENTIALLY
HAVE PARTISAN OFFICIALS
OVERTURNING RESULTS ARE THE ONES
MOST DISTURBING TO ME.
AND IT'S HARD TO GAUGE BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE EXACT
STRUCTURE OF EACH STATE'S VOTING
RULES AND ELECTION COMMISSIONS.
BUT IT JUST STRIKES ME THAT NONE
OF THAT CAN BE GOOD.
>> GEORGE, I WANTED TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON A FASCINATING VIGNETTE
FROM A NEW BOOK OUT BY MICHAEL
BENDER AT THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL.
IT TALKS ABOUT THIS ENCOUNTER
BETWEEN THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THEN VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE,
AND IT SAYS THIS WAS ACTUALLY
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED AFTER
PENCE'S POLITICAL COMMITTEE HAD
HIRED COREY LEWANDOWSKI WHO WAS
THE PRESIDENT'S ADVISER.
HE WRITES THIS.
HE, MENNING TRUMP, CRUMPLED THE
ARTICLE AND THREW IT AT HIS VICE
PRESIDENT.
SO DISLOYAL, MR. TRUMP SAID.
MR. PENCE LOST IT.
MR. PENCE PICKED UP THE ART
COMPANY AND THREW IT BACK AT
MR. TRUMP.
HE LEANED FORWARD TOWARD THE
PRESIDENT AND POINTED A FINGER A
FEW INCHES FROM HIS CHEST.
"WE WALK YOU THROUGH EVERY
DETAIL OF THIS," MR. PENCE
SNARLED.
WITH HE DID THIS FOR YOU AS A
FAVOR AND THIS IS HOW YOU
RESPOND.
YOU NEED TO GET YOUR FACTS
STRAIGHT.
I JUST WONDER WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THIS CHALLENGES THE VERY PUBLIC
FACE THAT PENCE PUT ON WHERE HE
WAS SO COMPLIMENTARY AND SO
DIFFERENTIAL TO TRUMP.
>> WELL, I THINK THE MORAL OF
THE STORY IS YOU CAN ONLY TAKE
SO MUCH, EVEN MIKE PENCE.
I CAN ONLY SAY, THOUGH, THAT I
WISH THAT WE HAD SEEN A LITTLE
MORE OF THAT MIKE PENCE PUBLICLY
AND NOT HEARD IT AFTER
EVERYTHING WAS OVER WHEN PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO REHABILITATE THEIR
REPUTATIONS.
I MEAN, THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
PUSHBACK ON THE PRESIDENT AND
MORE PUSHBACK PUBLICLY ON THE
PRESIDENT WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP -- WHEN HE DID OUTRAGEOUS
THINGS.
I JUST WISH WE HAD SEEN MORE OF
THAT FROM MIKE PENCE.
>> THE BOOK ALSO SUGGESTS THAT
AFTER THE ELECTION, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WANTED TO REPLACE BILL
BARR AS ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH
JOHN RATCLIFFE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WHAT I FIND MOST INTERESTING
ABOUT THAT IS RADCLIFFE HAD THE
SMARTS NOT TO TAKE THE JOB.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, IT JUST SHOWS
YOU THAT YOU CAN ONLY -- YOU CAN
NEVER PLEASE THE MAN.
BILL BARR DID SO MUCH TO HUMOR
DONALD TRUMP, AND YET IT WASN'T
ENOUGH.
I MEAN, IT WASN'T ENOUGH,
BECAUSE AS DESCRIBED IN I THINK
JONATHAN KARL'S EXCERPT WHICH
COVERS SOME OF THE SAME
MATERIAL, IT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR
TRUMP BECAUSE TRUMP -- BARR
DIDN'T, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
ENGAGE IN LITIGATION ON BEHALF
OF THE FAKE ELECTION FRAUD
CLAIMS.
HE DIDN'T INDICT HUNTER BIDEN.
HE DIDN'T ISSUE THE DURHAM
REPORT.
HE DIDN'T INDICT JIM COMEY.
NOTHING WAS EVER ENOUGH FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
AND THE REASON WHY IT GOT SO OUT
OF HAND WAS, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
DIDN'T PUSH BACK AT THE INTERIM
STEPS.
THEY ACCEDED TO SOME OF HIS
DESIRES AND WISHES IN CERTAIN
WAYS, AND BARR WAS THE
BIGGEST -- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PEOPLE HUMORING TRUMP.
AND IT JUST GETS WORSE AND WORSE
AND WORSE.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHY I SAID JUST A MOMENT
AGO, I WISH MIKE PENCE HAD
PUSHED BACK A LITTLE MORE.
BUT THEN AGAIN, YOU KNOW, HE
WOULDN'T BE RENOMINATED IN 2020,
AND THAT'S THE RISK HE WAS
PUSHING.
AND WITH BARR, HE RUNS THE RISK
OF BEING FIRED.
THAT WAS SORT OF THE MORAL OF
THE STORY IN A LOT OF WAYS ABOUT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, IS
THAT PEOPLE WERE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR JOBS THAN ABOUT
PRINCIPLE AND ABOUT PUSHING BACK
ON THE PRESIDENT, ABOUT DOING
THE RIGHT THING.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE ARE WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
>> SO, I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT MIKE POMPEO'S PORTRAYAL
HERE.
HE CERTAINLY WOULD FIT INTO THE
CATEGORY.
THIS BOOK REVEALS HE WARNED
COLLEAGUES, QUOTE, THE CRAZIES
HAVE TAKEN OVER AS TRUMP'S FRAUD
CONSPIRACY THEORIES WERE GROWING
AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> THAT'S REALLY NICE THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT AND HE SAID THAT
PRIVATELY.
WHY DIDN'T HE GO -- COME HERE,
GO ONTO FOX AND SAY THAT?
WHY?
AND WE'RE ALL HEARING IT NOW.
OH, THE CRAZIES WERE THERE.
THERE WAS NOBODY THERE TO PUSH
BACK.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
LOOK, IT'S RUDY GIULIANI'S
FAULT.
WELL, YOU COULD HAVE SAID
SOMETHING AT THE TIME, ALL THESE
FOLKS.
AND THEY DIDN'T.
AND THAT'S THE MOST OUTRAGEOUS
THING ABOUT IT.
THEY KNEW BETTER.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO SAY
PRIVATELY, HE LOST THE ELECTION.
SHHH.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT PUBLICLY.
THEY NEEDED TO DO IT PUBLICLY.
AT LEAST I COULD GIVE BARR SOME
CREDIT AND McCONNELL WHO PUT
BARR UP TO IT, GIVE HIM SOME
CREDIT FOR SAYING WE DIDN'T SEE
ENOUGH FRAUD.
BUT THAT WAS BASICALLY THE
EXTENT OF IT.
EVERYBODY ELSE JUST KEPT THEIR
MOUTH SHUT.
OH, IT WILL JUST RUN ITS COURSE.
HE'LL -- SOONER OR LATER HE'LL
ACCEPT THE RESULTS.
NO, HE WON'T.
THAT'S NOT WHO HE IS.
>> DO YOU THINK WE'LL EVER GET
ANSWERS, GEORGE, HERE?
I IMAGINE IT WILL TAKE YEARS,
BUT DO YOU THINK WE WILL EVER
GET ANSWERS FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THESE POSITIONS TO DO THIS
AND WILL REFLECT ON THIS YEARS
FROM NOW IN A HISTORICAL WAY AND
ANSWER THAT QUESTION?
WHY DIDN'T YOU STAND UP?
>> I'D LIKE TO HEAR THAT.
I REALLY WOULD.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR THAT BECAUSE A
LOT OF PEOPLE KNEW BETTER.
LOOK, IT'S LINGERING.
IT'S THE SAME THING CONNECTED TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
>> IT'S THE SAME CONNECTION TO
REPUBLICANS IN OFFICE WHO WERE
AFRAID OF LOSING THEIR JOBS.
>> RIGHT.
IT GOES TO THE SAME REASON WHY
YOU SEE JUST MINOR PUSHBACK
AGAINST MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
AS IT WAS REPORTED LAST HOUR.
OH, COULD YOU DO THIS LITTLE
SHOW ON TV JUST TO MAKE UP FOR
IT?
THEY DON'T PUNISH HER FOR SAYING
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS.
YET, ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU'VE
GOT LIZ CHENEY, WHO LOSES HER
LEADERSHIP POSITION BECAUSE SHE
SIMPLY TOLD THE TRUTH.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
NOBODY -- PEOPLE ARE NOT WILLING
TO BASICALLY TELL, NOT JUST
TRUMP, BUT THE REPUBLICAN BASE
GENERALLY THAT HERE'S THE TRUTH,
AND WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT
TRUTH.
AND WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THE TRUTH
THAT DONALD TRUMP LOST, WE HAVE
TO -- AND HERE ARE THE REASONS
WHY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT -- IT'S
NOT BROWN SHIRT TACTICS TO MAKE
PEOPLE OR TO URGE PEOPLE TO TAKE
THE VACCINE.
DONALD TRUMP BRAGS ABOUT HAVING
CREATED -- DOESN'T EVEN MAKE ANY
SENSE.
AND YET THERE'S NOT THAT
PUSHBACK.
THERE IS NOT THAT LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR INDIVIDUAL
POLITICAL CAREERS.
McCARTHY BECOMING SPEAKER --
THAN THEY ARE ABOUT DOING THE
RIGHT THING FOR THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS, AND FOR THEIR OWN
PARTY.
AND IT'S JUST -- IT'S
SELF-DESTRUCTIVE.
IT'S THE REASON WHY THEY LOST
THE PRESIDENCY AND T